[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى
360 كالعاده نبدا بابرز العناوين
حجم الدماء في بخموت يساوي النصره
بالهزيمه
تقترب من نسخ تجربه موسكو فيرسون وخرك
لغز تسميم الطالبات في ايران يتواصل
السلطات تحذر من تسميم المجتمع بالظاهر
والاهالي يشتركون مع الامن
تخطط القوات التركيه والفصائل المواليه
لها الدخول الى منبج والى كوباني المجاوره
وترفعه العربيه تصل خط المواجهه المحتمل
مع تركيا حاله اجتياح منبج وقصد تتوعد
انقره بترتيبات عسكريه مفاجئه
لدينا في 360 ايضا
بعد هجوم ترامب الذي لم يستثني حتى رموزا
جمهوريا يرى ان الوقت حان لمرشحين لا
يشوهون سمعه امريكا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
130 هجوما في اربع وعشرين ساعه الى هذه
الدرجه تلقي روسيا بثقلها وراء السيطره
على مخموت وفي المقابل تستمت اوكرانيا في
الدفاع عن المدينه رغم فداحه الخسائر لكن
ما يلوح في الافق امام هو سيناريو روسي
مؤلم جرب في خركات وخيرسون وتبريره دائما
ما يكون سهلا الانسحاب التكتيكي واعاده
الانتشار
وهذه نصر وهزيمه وشكان لم يبث فيها بعد من
الغالب ومن المغلوب لكن الحديث اليوم عن
تضاؤل فرص المقاومين الاوكرانيين في بخموت
المعركه في المدينه منذ اغسطس الماضي
ووفقا لاخر المعلومات تبدو قريبه
بالنهايتها نهايه لا يريد كلا المتحاربين
الخروج منها مهزومه
سيناريوهان ثالث لهما امامك
اما الانسحاب خلصت بعد تدمير الجسور
والطرق لكسب الوقت وابطاء القوات الروسيه
ومنعها من التوجه غربا في العمق الاوكراني
او الانتظار حتى الاستسلام لكن هذا الخيار
قد ينتهي بكارثه عسكريه بالنسبه الى
القوات المدافعه عن المدينه
بالمقابل تعمل روسيا على قطع الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانيه في قلب المدينه وضرب
طوق كامل حولها المقاومه الاوكرانيه
المستمره منذ ثمانيه اشهر استنزفت الكثير
من قدرات القوات المهاجمه حيث تسعى
لانسحاب محكم وبشروط هي من يصوعها على ارض
المعركه
خلال الهجوم يتقدمون في مجموعات من خمسه
او عشرين عنصرا نحن نبدو لقصار جهدنا
لضربهم هناك الكثير منهم ماتوا وجثثهم
منتشره في جميع انحاء الميدان بين الترقب
للنصر وهزيمه في بخموت قد تكون الساعات
القادمه حبلى بالمفاجات مفاجات قد تاتي
بانتصار رمزي انتظرته موسكو طويلا وهزيمه
لا تريدها وان كانت بطعم النصر
[تصفيق]
منضم الى يوريسات مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني سيد ساك اهلا بكم معنا ما هي
حقيقه الوضع في بخموت يعني هناك روايات
روسيه وهناك ايضا روايات اوكرانيه هل يمكن
ان تعطينا صوره واضحه ما هو الوضع هناك
الان
مساء الخير
ينبغي ان اقول ان الوضع على الارض دسم
بصعوبه بالغه لفتره من الزمن
الواقع ان المعتدين الروس حاولوا السيطره
على مخموت منذ نحو سته شهور دون تحقيق اي
نجاح هذا يعني ان الجيش الاوكراني
يواصلوا في
التاثير على القوات الروسيه
والروس
يستخدمون
جنودهم
مدافع او كادوات للحرب في هذه المعركه
وقد قتلنا 930 جنديا الكثيرون منهم قتلوا
داخل بخموت وحولها وبالتالي فان الروس
يواصلنا مساعيهم لمهاجمه ضخمه بالامس على
سبيل المثال حاولوا حوالي ثلاثين مره
لسيطره على مواقع الجيش الاوكراني لكن
الجنود الاوكراني يواصلون الدفاع عن
مواقعهم اما بالنسبه للوضع في مدينه بخموت
بخموت قبل الحرب كان يسكنها 70 الف نسمه
والان هناك حوالي اربعه او خمسه الاف شخص
والاجلاء من مخموت اضحى مستحيل بسبب
استمرار عمليه القصف
كما قال
رئيسنا من قبل فان الجيش الاوكراني سيواصل
الدفاع عن بخموت كلما استطاع ذلك لكن هذا
لا يعني اننا سوف نواصل الدفاع عنها اذا
لم نرى ضروره
عسكريه لاننا نكترث بحياه جنودنا اي اننا
لن ندافع عن بخموت باي ثمن الان نحن نقاوم
وهذا سمح لجيشنا في جبهات اخرى بالاستعداد
للهجوم المعاكس متى ترون بانه يجب ان
تخرجوا من باخموت
ايضا روسيا قالت بان هذا تكتيك وانسحبت هل
من الممكن ان يكون هناك سيناريو مماثل من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في باخمت متى
تفكرون ان تنسحبوا
عن هذه معلومات متاحه فقط
للقياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي ليس بوسعي انه على اللقاء على
الخطط العسكريه ما اقوله اننا سنواصل
الدفاع عن المدينه كلها ما استطعنا ذلك ما
نركز عليه الان هو سلامه منهم محاصرون في
بخموتهم يعيشون في
القبو المباني وليس لديهم مياه او ادويه
والقوات الروسيه حطمت كافه المباني ربما
هناك مبنى واحد لا يزال قائما وبالتالي
فان نواصل نحن التركيز على سلامه المدنيين
اسمح لي سيد جوري ان تبقى معنا لنعود اليك
ايضا لمناقشه موضوع الاصدقاء لاوكرانيا
الذين يمدونها بالاسلحه ولكن بعد ان نتابع
ماذا يجري في استونيا فاذا مشاهدينا الى
صناديق الاقتراع توجه مواطنوا استونيا
لاختيار اعضاء البرلمان الجديد في
انتخابات تخيم عليها
ظلال الازمه الاوكرانيه يعد الامن القومي
في عقبه هجوم روسيا المجاوره على اوكرانيا
والقضايا الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه من
القضايا الرئيسيه للانتخابات عندما نحينا
السياسه الداخليه جانبا فتشكل حرب
اوكرانيا عاملا مهما في هذه الانتخابات
استونيا كانت اشد الداعمين لاوكرانيا منذ
بدايه الحرب الدوله الواقعه في منطقه
البلطيق والعضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والناتو على راس الدول التي اطلقت نداءات
د العامه الماضي لزياده المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا في مواجهه الغزو
الروسي لم تكتفي استونيا بالدعوه لدعم
اوكرانيا بل انها تعتبر اكبر دوله مساهمه
في الجهود الغربيه
بالمقارنه مع حجم اقتصادها بانفاقها اكثر
من واحد في المئه من نتجها المحلي على دعم
اوكرانيا السياسيا وعسكريا استونيا بحسب
احصاءات رسميه سلمت الى اوكرانيا ترسانتها
الكامله من مدافع من بين معدات اخرى كما
انها استقبلت اكثر من 62 الف لاجئ
الاوكراني في اعلى نسبه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قياسا بعدد السكان اما على صعيد
العقوبات تريد استونيا اقرارا تخفيض فوريا
لسقف اسعار النفط الروسي وفرد قيود مماثله
على صادرات الغاز الطبيعي من موسكو الدعم
الاستوني لاوكرانيا تحدث عنه وزير
الخارجيه اور سالوا لمجالات نيوزك قائلا
ان الدول الغربيه ما زالت تقدم لاوكرانيا
ما تحتاجه للبقاء وليس للنصر مطالبا
بزياده الدعم الغربي واضاف الوزير ان اي
انتصار لروسيا سيضعوا الغرب في ورطه وربما
قد يؤدي هذا لمسح استونيا من الخريطه على
حد قوله على الجانب الاخر يرى زعيم حزب
الشعب المحافظ مارتن هيل ان على استونيا
تجنب زياده حده التوتر مع موسكو كما يركز
الحزب على حملته على معارضه تقديم مساعده
عسكريه اضافيه لاوكرانيا وعدم استقبال
مزيد من اللاجئين الاوكرانيين او من
جنسيات اخرى
[موسيقى]
تاريخ استونيا زاخر بالكثير من المحطات
المؤلمه لشعبها سيطر عليها الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام 1940 ثم استولت على البلاد
قواته المانيا النازيه بعدها بعام قبل ان
تعود للسيطره السوفيتيه عام 1944 ولم
تغادر حتى نالت البلاد استقلالها عام 1991
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه قتل ما يقدر
بنحو ربع المواطنين الاستونيين في واحد من
اعلى المعدلات في كل اوروبا ثم ادت عقود
من السيطره السوفيتيه الى عمليات ترحيل
جماعي واختفاء رئيسه الوزراء الحاليه كايا
كلاس اعادت ربط الحاضر باحداث الحرب
العالميه الثانيه خلال كلمه لها الشهر
الماضي امام مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
[موسيقى]
يمكن للجميع رؤيه ما يتحدث عنه بوتين انه
جاد بالفعل في عام
1925 لم يصدق احد هتلر لكنه كان واضحا في
اهدافه وفي عام 2007 كان بوتين هنا في هذا
المؤتمر واضح جدا بشان اهداف روسيا كانت
المشكله ان احد لم يصدق ولكن دعونا نصدقه
الان لنتمكن من اتخاذ القرارات على
المديين المتوسطي والطويل
الاوكرانيه كان حاضرا وبقوه على مناقشات
الحملات الانتخابيه في عده دول اوروبيه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه في ايطاليا مثلا حدث
تبين بين اطراف الائتلاف الثلاثي الذي فاز
في انتخابات سبتمبر الماضي فبينما اعلنت
جورجيا
كان حليفها في الائتلاف
ماتيوسلفيو على علاقات وثيقه مع موسكو حتى
اعتبر ان الرئيس الروسي
دفع بل دفع دفعا لغزو اوكرانيا في اكتوبر
الماضي لم يؤثر الخلاف السياسي الداخلي في
السويد على توجهات ستوكه
في وقت تواصل فيه السويد سعيها للانضمام
وبين يساري ويمين المشهد السياسي السويدي
تواصل السويد اوكرانيا حتى بعد وصول حزب
ديمقراطيه السويد اليميني للسلطه
[موسيقى]
اعود من جديد الى السيد جوري ساك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني من كاب سيد ساك ما
هي الحسابات العسكريه لديكم في حيل اصبح
هناك اي تغيرات في الدول المحيطه بكم يعني
نحن امام انتخابات في العدد من الدول
المحيطه بكم ومن الممكن ان تتغير القيادات
وتتغير الاحزاب المسيطره في البلاد وهذه
الاحزاب يكون لها راي اخر بموضوع مساعده
اوكرانيا والوقوف الى جانبها فما هي
حساباتكن العسكريه بهذا الصدد
الاحزاب السياسيه والقاده والامور كلها
يمكن ان تتغير باستثناء شيء واحد وهو ان
روسيا تواصل
التصرف كما
يدرك هذه الحقيقه هم يدركون لا سيما اولئك
الجيران الدول المجاوره لنا دول البلطيق
بولندا والمجر وسلوفاكيا ورومانيا هذه
البلدان التي
كانت تحت تاثير الكبير
للطغيان الاتحاد السوفياتي اذا الجميع
يدرك الان بان ما يسعى اليه الكريم هو
يحيى
امبراطوريه التحسن
الشريره التي تمثل روسيا وهذه البلدان
تدرك جيدا بان بوتين يجب ان يتوقف
شكرا لانه اذا لم يحدث ذلك فان البلدان
التاليه ستكون هي الاهداف اللاحقه وهذا
طبعا يعطي ثقه كبيره لنا فيما يخص دعم
جيرانينا وكذلك تحالف الدول الحره في
العالم لان الجميع يدرك الشر الذي نتعامل
معه وعلينا ان نهزمه على في ساحه المعركه
في اوكرانيا لان هذا سوف يحدد مصير اوروبا
ليس مصير اوكرانيا فقط طيب سيد ساك ايضا
هناك حقيقه بان معظم الدول الاوروبيه يعني
بدا ينفذ منها الذخائر لانها تقدم بقوه
كبيره الى اوكرانيا الى اي مدى تثقون بان
هذه الدول ستستمر في مدكم بهذه الاسلحه
التي كان لها الاثر الكبير لصمودكم حتى
هذه الساعه
بان جيراننا وحلفاءنا في الغالب في العالم
وفي اوروبا يدركون جيدا احتياجات الجيش
الاوكراني على ساحه المعركه نحن نخوض حربا
من حيث حجمها هي الاكبر منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
والوتيره التي بها يتم استخدام الذخائر
على ساحات المعركه هو امر غير مسبوق طبعا
لم يكن احد مستعد قبل عام 2022 لحرب من
هذا الحجم مع استخدام هذا الكم الهائل من
المدفعيه والمدرعات واي معدات عسكريه اخرى
لكننا واثق ايضا لان العلماء يدركون هذا
الواقع ونعلم ان هذا الامر حاصل هؤلاء
يزيدون الان انتاج الذخائر الكثير من
البلدان في اوروبا بدات
العمل على مدار الساعه من اجل ضمان ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تحصل على القدر
الكافي من الذخائر هذه ليست بالعمليه
السريع التي يمكن ان تنجز بين عشيه وضحاها
ولكنها عمليه سوف تضمن بان الجيش
الاوكراني سوف يواصل ليس الدفاع عن
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وانما سيحرر اراضينا
وهذا هو هدفنا الاساسي شكرا لك منك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني على المشاركه معنا
في 360
في العربيه 360 متابع
الخصومه تتكرس بومبيو يدعو الامه لتجاوز
المرشحين السابقين لمنصب الرئيس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا رئيس جامعه
الاحواز للعلوم الطبيه تسمم اكثر من 300
طالبه ايرانيه في مدن تابعه لمحافظه
الاحواز بينها الاحواز العاصمه وافادت
ايران انترناشونال باستهداف نحو 80 مدرسه
في انحاء ايران اليوم
فيل اثناء قال وزير التعليم الايراني يوسف
نوري ان تحقيقات لا تزال جاريه في حوادث
التسمم وانها لن تصل حتى الان لاي نتيجه
حول الجهه المتورطه اما المتحدث باسم
الحكومه فاكد انه سيتم تقديم المسؤولين
الى العداله لمحاسبتهم
[موسيقى]
وبعد ساعات من زياره مدير عام وكاله
الطاقه الذريه الى ايران خرجت منظمه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه لتنفي التوصل الى
اي اتفاق على تركيب كاميرات جديده في
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه اجهزه المراقبه
هذه كان قد تم وضعها بموجب الاتفاق النووي
لعام 2015 لكن طهران ازالتها العام الماضي
وقال المتحدث باسم المنظمه الايرانيه
بهروس كمال وندي انه لم يحدث بل لم يحدث
اي نقاش او اتفاق لتركيب هذه الكاميرات
في سياق متصل قال الرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانياهو ان تصريحات
رئيس الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه رافايا
الجروس بلا قيمه وتسائل نتانياهو لماذا
اعتبر غروسيا ان اي هجوم عسكريه على
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه امر محظور
مشيرا الى ان ايران تدعو بشكل واضح الى
تدمير اسرائيل وان العالم
يدعم موقفه الابيب في الدفاع عن نفسها
امام اي عدوان
المشاهدين التقدم في البرنامج الايراني
النوويه
يخرج الغرب
ويضع الدول الموقعه على الاتفاق النووي
امام اختبار صعب الحديث هنا لصحيفه
الفرنسيه التي قالت ان كلا من فرنسا
والمانيا وبريطانيا من جهه والولايات
المتحده من جانب اخر تواجه مازقا كبيرا
ازاء تطور البرنامج النووي لزهراء فمنذ
الوقف الكامل لمحاولات احياء الاتفاق
النووي في سبتمبر الماضي تبدو هذه الدول
بحسب لمود امام معضلتين اما الاعتراف
العلني بنهايه الاتفاق والدخول في المجهول
او ارتفاع خطر التصعيد بين عقوبات
اقتصاديه جديده مشدده على ايران او حدوثه
عمليات عسكريه محتمله وخلال التعليق
المتواصل للمباحثات والمستمر منذ شهور
ساعدت ايران من الانتهاكات المتعدده
الالتزاماتها بموجب الاتفاق النووي وفق
الصحيفه رموض نقلت عن رفاي المدير لعمل
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قوله انه
حاول من خلال زيارته لطهران يوم الجمعه
الماضي الحفاظ على خيط من المناقشات مع
النظام الايراني لمحاوله استعاده السيطره
على انشطته بروسيل تقع امس ايضا الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس للمره الاولى وهي
علامه ايجابيه في حد ذاتها بحسب جروسي
الذي قال ان الوكاله تتخذ خطوه في الاتجاه
الصحيحه وكاله الطاقه الذريه كشفت ان
طهران وافقت على عوده كاميرات المراقبه
لبعض المواقع النوويه والسماح للمفتشين
بالوصول الى اماكن رفضت طهران سابقا
الوصول اليها اضافه لزياده عمليات التفتيش
بنسبه 50% في منشاه فوردو لكن كما ذكرنا
خرجت وكاله الطاقه الذريه لتنفئه تماما
موضوع الكاميرات نتابع
[موسيقى]
اتفقنا على عدد من الاجراءات الملموسه
فخلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه كان هناك
انخفاض في بعض انشطه المراقبه لذا قررنا
مضاعفتها ووضع المزيد من الكاميرات وتعزيز
انظمه التطبيق عبر الانترنت واصلاح المعطل
منها المهم بالنسبه لنا هو ان ايران
ستلتزم بدرجه التخصيب المحدده لها في
منشاه فوردو وستحترم هذا الالتزام
بالفرنسيه اعتبرت ان توقف المفاوضات الدفع
الايرانيين لمواصله التجاوسات المحسوبه
وعلى الرغم من خطوره الموقف والانقطاع
الطويل في المراقبه الدوليه للانشطه
الايرانيه الا ان دولا كالولايات المتحده
لا يبدو انها تصب اهتمامها في هذه المرحله
على الملف النووي الايراني واشارت الصحيفه
الفرنسيه في هذا الصدد الى تعليق الرئيس
جو بايدن خلال اجتماعا حزبي في نوفمبر
الماضي وقوله ان الاتفاق النووي مات الا
ان الولايات المتحده لن تعلن وفاته بعد
كما ذكرت الصحيفه بتصريح مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي بان المفاوضات مع ايران
ليست على جدول الاعمال اعمال الاداره
الامريكيه في الوقت الراهن
احد الاسباب التي دفعت الاداره الى العوده
للاتفاق النووي هو ان ايران كانت غير
مقيده في مواصله عمليات التخصيب وتقليل
وقت الاختراق الى اسابيع وربما شهور لكن
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران ليس في دائره
اولوياتنا في الوقت الراهن في ايران تواصل
تزويد روسيا بالمعدات والقدرات العسكريه
للاستمرار في قتل الاوكرانيين وتدعم
الارهابيين في الشرق الاوسط كما تستمر في
قمع التظاهرات في المدن الايرانيه لذلك
الامر ليس محطه اهتمام الاداره
اسرائيل على الجهه الاخرى تواصل دراسه ما
يمكنها لمواجهه البرنامج النووي لايران
لموند اشارت الى ان وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
ومستشاره الامن القومي الساحل
سيتوجهان الى واشنطن خلال الايام المقبله
لمناقشه خيارات الرد على ايران واليوم
انتقد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو حديثه
مدير عام الوكاله الذريه رافايا الجروس
وقوله ان اي هجوم على المنشات الايرانيه
سيعتبر عملا خارجا عن القانون نتابع
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه رفائيل جروس
سي اعلن في طهران ان الهجوم الاسرائيليه
على المنشات النوويه خارج عن القانون خارج
عن اي قانون بالنسبه لشخص مسؤول مثل جروسي
هل يجوز لايران التي تدعو بصراحه ووضوح
الى تدميرنا وان تحضر الادوات لقتلنا من
الواضح انه مسموح لنا بالدفاع عن انفسنا
لكن السؤال الى اي مدى وصل تطور البرنامج
النووي الايراني ومتى بامكانها صنع قنبله
او قنابل نوويه معهد العلوم والان الدولي
الامريكي توقع في تقرير له انه يمكن
لايران انتاج ما يكفي من المواد المستخدمه
في صنع الاسلحه لصنع قنبله نوويه في غضون
12 يوما فقط وانتاج اربع قنابل اخرى في
غضون شهر واحد تقرير المعهد حلل فيه
المعلومات التي قدمتها الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه واشاد الا انه يمكن للنظام
الايراني تخصيب ما يكفي من اليورانيوم
لتصنيع ما مجموعه سبعه اسلحه نوويه في
ثلاثه اشهر وتظهر النتائج ان ايران اقرب
من اي وقت مضى الى تجاوز العتبه النوويه
خاصه وان طهران قامت في الاشهر الاخيره
بتخصيب اليورانيوم الى مستويات اقل بقليل
من مستويات الاسلحه وهو ما اثار مخاوف من
ان ايران ربما تكون في طريقها نحو اختبار
سلاح نووي في اي لحظه لكن بالعوده الى
تقرير لمون فبحسب هذا التقرير ما يزال
امام ايران بين عام ونصف وعامين ونصف
للوصول الى سلاح نووي اخذا في الاعتبار
تخزين كميه مناسبه من اليورانيوم المخصب
عند 90% ثم صنع الراس النووي ودمجه في
صاروخ مناسب
[موسيقى]
من برلين ينضم الى مصطفى العمار اقعدوا
مجلس امناء حزب الاتحاد المسيحي
الديمقراطي سيد العمار اهلا بكم معنا
بالنسبه لايران كيف تنظر الان الى هذا
الاتفاق الايرانيين هل من الممكن ان
بالنسبه لها مات ام مازال هناك فرص يمكن
ان تعطى لهذا الاتفاق
مساء الخير عليك وعلى المشاهدين الكرام
واولا كل عام والعربيه بخير وتقدم وازدهار
دائم ان شاء الله طبعا اعتقد انه هذه
المساعي كلها التي يسعى لها للاسف يعني
سياسه الدوليه هي عباره عن مساعي فاشله
لان نتعامل هنا مع نظام فاقد للشرعيه مع
نظام ارهابي لا مصداقيه له واعتقد انه على
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يغير سياسته تجاه
ايران لان هذه المماطله مع ايران سوف لن
تجدي باي ثمار ما شاهدنا ايضا في السنوات
السابقه وللاسف كان هناك تطور الى المفاعل
انه الايراني وهذه كلها ما يجب ان هي
عباره عن تخدير لربما من قبل الجانب
الايراني الى المجتمع الدولي بانهم يحترم
القوانين ويحترم الشرعيه الدوليه لكن هو
عكس ما هذا والمعطيات جدا واضحه طيب ولكن
بالنسبه لالمانيا برايك من الممكن ان تبقي
على اي حظ لا تعطي فرصه جديده لهذا
الاتفاق ام اصبحت مقتنعه بانه لا حياه
لهذا الاتفاق مهما كان الثمن
اتمنى ان يكون هناك ايضا تصريح من قبل
اتمنى ان يكون يقول تصريح بان هناك لا
حياه لهذا الاتفاق النووي ابدا الى الان
لا يوجد اي تصريح واضح للاسف من الحكومه
الالمانيه للاسف لا يوجد هناك ايضا اي
تحركات على الرغم من ان ايران تاخذ
المواطنين الالمان عباره عن هناك عقوبات
اعدامى وجه المواطن الالماني من اصول
الايرانيه هناك قمع هناك ايضا اختراق
لحقوق الانسان تسمم وغيرها من الانتهاكات
لكن للاسف الحكم الالماني هنا منشقه هناك
الحزب الليبرالي يصرح ويمدد ويقول يجب ان
لا يكون هناك اتفاق نووي السيده انا
لنبربوك معروفه بمواقفها مع حقوق الانسان
لكن كابن السيد
لا يكون هناك احياء الى هذا الموقف النووي
وان ايضا ان يكون هناك تعاون المانيا ان
تبقي على تنسيق بمواقفها مع الدول
الاوروبيه ام من الممكن ان تتفرد باي قرار
بخصوص هذا الاتفاق الايراني النووي
المانيا المانيا قبل فتره قالت بانها سوف
تكون وتستمع ايضا الى الشعب الايراني
لانهاء هذا الاتفاق النووي وايضا للمطالبه
بحقوقهم ووضع ايضا الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه الارهاب وجدنا ان هناك لا توجد
اي اي موضوع او اي نقاط في الملف الاجنده
الاتحاد الاوروبي بما قالته الحكم
الالماني للاسف وما نريده الان هو تغيير
لهذه السياسه هناك بدايه لسياسه جديده بان
لا تعطي لايران ايضا الحركه في تطوير سلاح
النووي هل من تصريح او موقف للحكومه
الالمانيه تجاه ما يحصل من سجال بين
اسرائيل وبين سيد جراسي
طبعا المانيا دائما وضعت اسرائيل بان يكون
امنها من الاولويات وامنها ايضا من امن
المانيا الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن الان لا
يوجد هناك اي رد من الحكومه الالمانيه على
مسرحه ايضا السيد نتنياهو الى الان نحن
ننتظر لربما اليوم احد لربما غدا سوف يكون
هناك تصريح وايضا نعول على زياره السيد
اوستن الذي سوف تبدا للشرق الاوسط خلال
الاسبوع هذا شكرا لك من برلين مصطفى
العماره عضو مجلس امناء حزب الاتحاد
المسيحيه الديمقراطي على المشاركه معنا في
[موسيقى]
مناطق شمال شرق سوريا لا تغيب ابدا عن
اعين تركيا بدات بالسيطره على مناطق عده
غربا بدعم من فصائل المعارضه ثم زحفت شرقا
حتى اوقفتها منطقه عين العرب كوباني التي
منعت التواصل الجغرافي بين مناطق سيطره
المعارضه شرق وغرب الفرات العربيه تمكنت
من الوصول الى منبج المجاوره لكوباني التي
كانت ضمن ثلاثه مناطق تشملها التهديدات
العسكريه التركيه وهناك رصدنا خريطه
النفوذ المعقده ووصلنا الى خط المواجهه
الاخير الذي يتواجد فيه النظام السوري
نتابع
[موسيقى]
طريق ينثر على اطراف الفاعلون في الملف
السوري نقاطهم الامنيه المتقاربه فمعادره
الامن هنا دقيقه ومعقده هذه مناطق محاذيه
لتركيا تسيطر عليها قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
قوات كرديه تتهمها انقره بتهديد امنها
وبربط علاقات مع حزب العمال كردستانيه لذا
ترفض اقترابها من الحدود وتراقب تحركاتها
جوا كما تضربها بين الحين والاخر
وتهددها بعمل بري كبير
التهديدات التركيه بشان عمليه عسكريه في
شمال شرق سوريا متواصله الهدف المعلن
اقامه منطقه امنه بعمق ثلاثين كيلومتر
ولتحقيق هذا المسعى تخطط القوات التركيه
والفصائل المواليه لها الدخول الى منبج
والى كوباني المجاوره وترفعت ما يعني
عمليا شريطا حدوديا خاضعا لتركيا من ادلب
الى حدود قامشلي
شريط يقطع اوصال منطقه كرديه ممتده في
المنطقه تعيد اليه تركيا اللاجئين
السوريين
تحاول ربط مناطق التي تحتلها في منطقه
الابيض
وجرابلس كل هذه الامور انا ما نجمعها
بدا حمله عسكريه هناك لكن ليس مرتبطه في
تعلم
نحن ناخذ هذه التهديدات بشكل جدي ونتعامل
معها بشكل جدي وحقيقه نستطيع السابقه كنا
نقوم بتحضيراتنا
لهكذا هجمه فبالتاكيد تحضيراتنا مستمره
وقواتنا في حال جاهزيه تامه
[موسيقى]
خطه تجعل قسد بحاجه الى هذه النقاط التي
نمر على مقربه منها
المعركه في منبج وكوباني وترفعت مختلفه
تخضع لخارطه النفوذ فمثلا حيث اقف الان
خلفي موقع عسكري تابع للنظام من المفترض
ان يكون هذا الموقع بالاضافه الى مواقع
اخرى تابعا النظام خط المواجهه الاول مع
القوات التركيه والفصائل المواليه لانقره
في حال قررت التقدم ودخول منبج لكن حسابات
السياسه وتجارب السابقه قد تفرض واقعا
مختلفا في حال قرر دمشق اتخاذ موقف الحياد
موقف حياد لا تتمناه قصد لكنها ترى بعض
مؤشراته حتى الان خجوله وتحركاتهم ايضا
خجوله وتحضيراتهم ايضا خجوله لكن لديهم
تواجد ونحن نامل على ان يكونوا يشاركوا
معنا في معركه ان حصلت كان هناك
اتفاق برعايه روسيه الانتشار حرس الحدود
التابع لقوات الحكومه دمشق هذه القوات
الموجوده حتى الان في الاونه الاخيره
الليزر قبل الاشهر كان هناك زياده عدد
القوات وهم متواجدون فبالتاكيد نحن كقوات
نؤكد ان القوات المتواجده على خطوط
التماسك مع الجانب التركي هي قوات حرس
الحدود التابعه النظام مع
تدابير لنا سي
روسيا التي تراقب المشهد من نقاطها
الامنيه هنا تعمل على تخفيض اي توتر يقوض
سياده حريفها النظام استرفض عملا عسكريا
للاطراك لكنها تعقد اتفاقيات لتسيير
دوريات مشتركه
مع كل هذا فيما تعزز وجودها قرب
الامريكيين المعنيين اولا بالحرب على داعش
صار ابن عشوباء الحدث من شمال شرق سوريا
[موسيقى]
حذر مختصون اتراك من حدوثه تغيير
ديموغرافي كبير في البلاد بسبب موجات
النزوح لعشرات الالاف من ضحايا الزلزال
وفيما يفضل البعض الفرار من الولايات
الجنوبيه المتضرره نحو مدن وسط شمال تركيا
شهدت كثير من القرى هجره عكسيه للباحثين
عن الامان
هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا خلال اولى ساعات
الصباحات انطاكيا المنكوبه فرار جماعي
للناجين من الزلزال الذي جعلها تاي من
اكبر المدن تضررا منهم من يملك وجهه محدده
ومنهم من سيحددها لاحقا خلال ساعات الرحله
الطويله بحثا عن الامان يعني ان على طلاق
غصب عني بابا يعني
[موسيقى]
رفقاتي منهم ماتوا منهم راحوا لله الامر
كل جيران في هذه البنايه والحي غادروا الى
مدن اخرى انا كذلك تقرر هدم بيت المتصدع
وساذهب الى انقره واعيش هناك عند اقاربه
كما السوريين الذين الفوا الترحاله دخل
الاتراك كذلك في هجره داخليه الى مدن
الشمال وعكسيه اعادت المئات منهم الى
القرى هنا بقريه جولباش بضواحيها تاي
ياملون النجاه بانفسهم من الزلزال وهزاته
المتتاليه لكن هذه السيده لا تامن الوضع
وتفضل الخيمه على البقاء داخل بيتها
منذ حدوث زلزال عدنا الى قرانه التي اصبحت
مزدحمه هي الاخرى هنا الوضع اقل خطوره من
مركز هاتاي لكني اخاف البقاء في البيت
لذلك انا في الخيمه
اما هذا الرجل فوجد نفسه لاجئا في خيمه
حتى وهو يعود الى قريته التي غادرها قبل
خمسه عقود من الاربعه وسبعين لها اليوم
هذا من القريه بعيد
على مكان الاول باركين بالخيام مع الندور
ما عندنا شيء
وفقا للارقام الرسميه فقد عاد اكثر من
اربعين الف سوري طواعيه الى سوريا فيما لم
يتم الكشف بعد عن اعداد المنكوبين من
الاتراك وغيرهم ممن نزحوا نحو مدن تركيه
اخرى
تطمينات السلطات التركيه اعمار المناطق
المتضرره سريعا لم توقف موجات النزوح
لعشرات الالاف من المنكوبين ما يؤشر الى
حدوث تغير ديموغرافي قد يزيد من متاعب
الحكومه في معالجه اثار الزلزال عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
في العربيه 360
في اوكرانيا الحرب شريط ذكريات مؤلم تراه
من النوافذ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مقاله وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق معك ان الوقت حان لتتجاوز الامه
المرشحين المشهورين للرئاسه فيما بدا
وكانها اشاره للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
يقال خلال استضافته في برنامج فوكس ان
ايران يجب ان تتجاوز الان لحظه امريكا يجب
ان تتجاوز اليوم لحظه المشاهير والنجوم
لان الوقت حان كي تعود الى اصولها
المحافظه وحين طلب منه توضيح تصريحات
سابقه عن المرشح المثالي للرئاسه قال
كومبيو انه وقت جديين المفكرين الذين لا
يشوهون سمعه امريكا ولا يقضون كل وقتهم في
التفكير بتويتر مذيعه البرنامج ضاغطت على
الاقرار بما اذا كان يقصد ترامب لكنه اكد
ان المقصود ليست ترامبول بايدن مشيرا الى
انه سيعلن موقفه من الترشح خلال شهرين
وفي ظهور صاخب كالعاده قدم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب نفسه كمرشح رئيسيا وحيد قادر
على ما وصفه بمهمه انقاذ الولايات المتحده
ممن يكرهونها ترامب الذي كان يتحدث في
المؤتمر السنوي للمحافظين الامريكيين لم
يدخر جهدا في مهاجمه كل خصومه الحاليين
والمفترضين مستقبلا حتى داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
كان لدينا حزب جمهوري يحكمه غريب اطوار
ومحافظون جدد ومؤيد وعولمه ومتعصب حدود
مفتوحه واغبياء لكننا لن نعود ابدا الى
حزب بور ريان وكاراف وجيب بوش
لم يقدر نفسه كمنقذا لامريكا فقط وانما
كمنقذ للعالم من خطر الحرب العالميه
الثالثه التي تقترب بحسب اعتقاده
[موسيقى]
لكني اقف هنا اليوم وانا المرشح الوحيد
القادر على الوفاء بهذا الوعد وسامع وبكل
سهوله الحرب العالميه الثالثه بسهوله
شديده
خطاب ترامب تستغرق ساعه واربعين دقيقه لذا
كان هناك متسع من الوقت للاشاره الى ان
الامريكيين السائموا من عائلات سياسيه
متجذره في الحزبين ومن مصالح خاصه متعفنه
وسياسيين محبين للصين وانصار حروب خارجيه
لنهايه لها طبعا كل هذا بحسب وصفه اما
اللافت ان الاجتماعات من هذا النوع كانت
في العاده ما تشهد مقاعد خاويه لكن خلال
خطاب ترامب كانت القاعه تقريبا ممتلئه
ومتابعه لما يجري في اجواء الانتخابات
القادمه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ينضم
الي من واشنطن حسين طوب مراسل العربيه
حسين اهلا بك معنا اذا اردنا ان ننظر الى
الحشود التي كانت موجوده نقول بانه ترامب
ما زال لديه وزن كبير بين الناس وانما
ايضا هناك صوره معاكسه من قبل الرموز
الجمهوريه كيف يمكن ان نفسر ما يجري على
الارض
تحيه لك ميسون بالفعل الارقام التي حصل
عليها ترامب تبدو مقلقه بالنسبه لقاده
الحزب الجمهوري كما يقول محللون اليوم
خلال
وجودهم على المواقع الامريكيه
والتلفزيونات الامريكيه ولكن هذا امر يبدو
طبيعي بالنسبه لمن يتابعون شعبيه ترامب
هنا التي وان بالفعل تضاءلت قليلا بعد
انتخابات تجديد النصفي وبسبب الاتهامات
التي او التحقيقات التي تجري حوله لكنه ما
زال يحافظ على الاغلبيه من او القاعده لدى
الجمهوريين على مستوى القاعده الشعبيه
هناك انتقادات بطبيعه الحال توجه له من
قاده الحزب الجمهوري من مثل
وغيرهم من القضاء الكبار في الحزب والذين
يدعون الى تهميش ترامب والى مرحله جديده
من القاده الجمهوريين بعيدا عن تربو مرحله
ما بعد ترامب حتى ان مموليه الحزب
الجمهوري الكبار يدعون الى وجود مرش اخر
بديل له لخوض انتخابات عام 2024 الرئاسيه
ولكن كل هذا على ما يبدو لم يؤثر على
شعبيه ترامب حتى الان والدليل النتائج
التي رايناها بالتصويت طب حسين هناك امر
اخر تصريحات بومبيو هل هي مؤشر على انه
سيكون سيترشح الى الانتخابات وايضا موضوع
العشرين بالمئه التي حاز عليها سانتوس
مستغربه الى حد ما خاصه بانه يعد المنافس
الاشرس للرئيس السابق ترامب
نبدا بتصريحات التي تصبها في خانه تصريحات
زعماء وقاده الحزب الجمهوري المعارضين كما
قلنا يؤيدون وجود مرشح اخر بديل لكي يفوز
ويواجه بها المرشح الديمقراطي بطبيعه
الحال من المحتمل ان يعلن ترشحه في الاشهر
المقبله وهذا امر الحديث عنه كثيرا وان
كان في استطلاعات الراي لا يستطيع ان
يتجاوز بالنسبه المئويه من الاصوات الخمسه
لماذا حصل على 20% في كل استطاعات الرايه
التي نطلع عليها
بنسبه كبيره ترامب دائما يحصل على اعلى
نسبه من على نسبه مئويه من الاصوات
امام كل المرشحين المهم تقريبا هناك
اعتقاد منهم سيكونون ما بين 13 مرشح
الجمهوريا و15 مرشحا دائما ترامب يحصل على
مباين
واربعين بالمئه من الاصوات هذه هذه
حصل عليها مؤخرا هي اعلى نسبه له ولكن هذا
لا يعني ان الروندا ضعيف ولكن هناك من
يقول بانه اذا كان يوجد عدد كبير من
المرشحين الجمهوريين الاصوات الجمهوريه
ستتقسم بينهم بينما سيحافظ ترامب على
كتلته التي تؤيده وهو ما يفسر بحصوله على
هذه النسبه الكبيره من الاصوات شكرا لك
حسين تعود مراسل العربيه كنت مع من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 انا مدين
للجميع ولا سيما لاسر الضحايا بطلب الصفح
كانت هذه رساله رئيس الوزراء اليوناني
كرياكوس
لشعبه بعد كارثه تصادم القطرين فيلا رساله
اودت في حياه قرابه 60 شخصا مثل تاكيس
اضافه انه في اليونان عام 20 23 لا يمكن
لقطارين ان يسير في اتجاهين معاكسين على
نفس الخط دون ان يلاحظهما احدا لكن اهم ما
في رسالته ربما ان حكمته لن تختبئ وراء
الخطا البشري المنسوب الى مدير المحطه
اما صوره اليوم فهي في الحقيقه مجموعه صور
من اوكرانيا للمصور ميجال جوتيريز ترصد
هذه الصور معاناه الاوكرانيين من نوافذهم
فخلف كل نافذه انفاس تحتبس وعيون تترقب قد
يكون مطره مختلفا لكن كل المشاهد في
النهايه ستترك قلوبا ترتجف
[موسيقى]
الى هنا تنتهي 360 ولكن اخبار العربيه لا
تنتهي ملفات جديده واخبار جديده مع زميل
صهيب شراير واخبار الساعه اليك صهيب ماذا
لدينا الليله مساء الخير مره اخرى ميسون
لدينا المزيد من التفاصيل حول مستجدات
المعركه في ضخمه تبقى في الصداره في ظل
الاحكام احكام السيطره الروسيه والحصار
الروسي عليها وكذلك ربما وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي سيمنع من دخول امريكا بعد
تصريحاته عن محو بلده حوار الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك